all right what is your name
Ruth Josh Brener uh-huh
hey my man you think your Ruth not sure
okay
I'm Magdalene no surrounded where'd you
grow up
where'd you grow up Africa Africa mm-hmm
and tell me about your family you grew
up with both of your parents
uh-huh mission with I hated that you
name
I'm sorry mr. McConaughey I did not grow
up with my parents know they were there
in part and what happened with your
parents they and this is some aid to
care for me and they turned out to be
ruthless in their pursuit of political
power and so part of them gaining
political power was to move and when we
moved we got contacts let me do with me
my folks I mean how old are you 10
you're 10 mm-hmm
honey giving a family
I prefer Marcin bet - Terry was my baby
no I'm nothing shake it do you have any
family
yes yes matter fact each basic as my
sister yeah she did the movie Carrie
perhaps you've heard of it
uh-huh Carrie have great hero tactic in
talking eight cards um talking he says I
was showing from everybody sister Ashley
let's return I'm going to hunt for one
in the you here if I don't have him back
ruth-marie where do you stay at night
yes do you stay in a tent in Whoville
alia yes I live in a camp yeah you're
welcome to visit okay do we have to you
something you uh did you [ __ ] all right
I didn't know that you are warlock the
one from the movie digging Lambert
reasonable you played the role in here
do you do any of the drugs that are on
the street I used I used something new
called pyramid recently that's a Android
drug it was very bad for me it ruined my
eyesight you know I'm sorry bad in
action it's not really I say I'm sorry
but I used methamphetamine crystal math
right and I used cocaine I'll see you a
little bit of Sun or angel dust hurry
what they've done is condenser angel
dust recently into a compound that takes
the life of the bearer the person that
you're making and it allows you to mimic
the person almost
personal I movement tenor timbre of wife
that sort of thing have you ever been to
any of the mental health facilities here
on Skid Row
yes but not under my true name and
formally afternoon what happened when
you were at these facilities
not anymore but darker I need offense
have you ever had professional mental
health care not very no not really no I
haven't not watch this not since I was
at the facility he's hurt and Girl
Interrupted I think that was in Boston
I've been a long time since I've been
there I've been undercover stay with my
husband Sean Connery since then since
after since escaping that my enough
memory returned to me the abbot a book
could be drawn away
I meant anybody how many years have you
been down here at Skid Row my machine
and I'm a diary though babe I'm sorry
Francis in that case right now okay you
know that okay
how many years have you been down here
on Skid Row um well of ten years I don't
know ready a long larger portion of my
life yeah most of it do you ever take
medications for your mental condition I
are concurring give me a couple of them
an oppressor which is the it largely a
female at the gene right yeah they're
considered give me that I'm running he
told me that he was gonna give it to me
victory okay you wanna make that tree
about image a little cleaver
I've seen it you had me already but you
didn't like the artist but he didn't
smile
he's what is known as a minute you're at
you can give any friends on the street
worth upon a few one of them is our Cora
coral he's actually she knew the I'm
Richelieu with singleton jr. I named it
and she is actually the actress behind
the she live performances you know my
painter argue back to everything they're
happy if I have you had any bad things
happen to you all you've been here on
the street
mini many okay so yeah what kind of
stuff happens to a little rates that we
can often oh well not race anymore of
taking the profession but was right
it's appear to rate that should I don't
think my parents understood that's late
teen yourself you weren't understated is
right maybe you would have thank you I
have maybe
do you have any children of your own
anything
do you have children of your honor um
okay
yes I have many I mean I have bars ever
higher
when everything's real servants to asses
I just threw the money you mean cheating
on my own yeah that's the 700 then ones
I'm talking about after them you know
please I couldn't have been there like
did I often said I step away children or
my tomorrow okay
are you certain your name is Ruth no I'm
not trying now but what do you think
your name it actually is I feel a root I
didn't know her friends I don't know
yeah I might not be the one someone told
me that was Esther or Ruth uh-huh okay
I'm not no okay I'm sorry
are you my wife one of the two sisters
in the Bible
that's your Ruth they were cool ooh
Mulaney you're not gonna go boom oh they
probably were you aren't all right
yesterday Ruth thank you very much
available community I'm Andre and Keith
are my cute children that were rescued
be something I haven't been there
sleeping buddy let me get her okay uh
keep it you heard that
okay though okay Esther Oh Ruth thank
you very much for okay oh do you fun
what are you gonna do here yeah a
picture I take take photographs here and
do the later views like this
okay are we friends we're friends
you